يعتبر الجيش السوداني من الجيوش المتوسطه
ويصنف بانه من اقوى جيوش القرن الافريقي
ويتكون من 205 الاف جندي منهم 100 الف من
القوات العامله و50 الف من قوات الاحتياط
تملك القوات الجويه السودانيه 1991 طائره
منها 45 مقاتله وسبع وثلاثون طائره هجوميه
وخمسه وعشرون طائره شحن ويعد الطيران من
اهم نقاط قوه الجيش في مواجهته مع قوات
الدعم السريع كما يملك الجيش السوداني 170
دبابه ونحو سبعه الاف مركبه عسكريه ويملك
389 مدفعا وهذه الاسلحه الثقيله تصب ايضا
في مصلحه الجيش اما قوات الدعم السريع فلا
توجد معلومات دقيقه بشانها ويقدر عدد
المسلحين التابعين لها بنحو 100 الف اما
اعتادها فيتشكل بالاساس من سيارات رباعيه
الدفع تحمل اسلحه متنوعه منها مضادات
طائرات وم دافع ويقدر عدد هذه سيارات بنحو
عشره الاف ويعطي هذا السلاح الخفيف قوات
الدعم السريع مرونه في الحركه خصوصا في
المواجهات داخل المدن واذا كان الجيش
السوداني يعتمد على ميزانيه الدوله في
تمويله فان قوات الدعم السريع تملك مناجم
ذهب تدر عليها اموالا طائله كما انخرطت في
انشطه تعليميه اخرى ودخلت مجال التجاره ما
مكنها من تمويل نشاطها العسكري